hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the world's easiest game
now as with most games like this it's
probably not gonna be actually that easy
so let's give it a go and see how this
goes
welcome to the world's easiest game your
reputation as an intelligent individual
precedes you that however is not the
name of the game today I'm queasy catnip
due to an unfortunate condition I cannot
stand the sight of a difficult question
all the following questions will be easy
I mean really easy
don't make them difficult or you will
fail like me you will get nine lives and
only nine I'll be timing you so get
ready alright let's do this oh boy you
walk into a restaurant in the room there
are 10 people who are 21 years old three
people who are sewing six years old 27
people are 29 years old 9 people who are
31 years old 17 of them are 17 are men
how many people are in the restaurant
what you said this was gonna be easy not
math the numbers add up to 29 oh there's
30 cuz there's also you there's 30 yes
ah which is the United States okay
alright well we're off to a flying start
a man wants to marry his widowed sister
can e know because he's deaf one two
three four phases then what's the next
number seven I'm on a roll which is
every repetitive the same neither
they're the same a pound is a pound
I had 27 flour sadly all but 14 died how
many are left 14 okay oh hi excuse me
sorry pardon me
[Music]
what's the number between 1 and 2 not 3
1.5 okay how many cups into court 4 ok
how many quarts in a gallon
okay well it's 2 plus 3 minus plus 7
minus 7 is 4 don't trade me for
something here how many sides this graph
or I don't like this
besides the regular I guess I'm lazy
this dog have I don't like this if you
take half of a spider's leg off because
you're cruel how many legs is a spider
have left for who's breezy how many
seasons of the year are there like this
how many fingers are on the human hand
well technically there's 4 fingers plus
a thumb but I'm gonna go with 5 because
you're being dumb how many plays oh God
according to the thing in the corner 17
cuz I've only answered those I'm on the
18th questions so 17 yes what's the
scene you'll be through all [ __ ] okay
alright then oh boy okay hi
are you distracting me Oh color was
clock who's red I think red yeah what
color was the sofa purple or pink ball
okay all right
whose house was it walk okay what a
better cats or dogs dogs
oh that's rule and dogs drool okay oh
come on you biased bastard water the
lawn and make the grass grow alright
pointed seeds
alright hello okay
okay all right then plan some pretty
flowers but I take the seeds now all
right okay now burn down the flowers
with your awesome flamethrower house
awesome I don't mind
let's do it type the number four okay I
don't like this I just hit four Mary and
Susie ordered pizza Mary ate two out of
four slices and Susie ate four out of
eight who ate more didn't they both eat
half isn't that how this works
neither no no any more all right okay
say is that North Carolina all right
world race car
is it same forward backwards and upside
down I'm not upside down
I need forwards and backwards yeah but
upside down no okay all right then trip
the mob boss what the [ __ ] hello hi
goodbye
sorry okay murdered yay swim to safety
oh okay okay wait up here no triangle is
the only basic staple sisa three sides
yes yeah okay grammar nazis beware which
is correct do you want to go to the mall
with John and me do you want to go to
the mall with John and I do you want
this one it's me that because what the
way you determine it is you take out the
other name and see what sounds right so
do you want to go to the mall with me or
do you want to go to the mall with I
that doesn't make any sense
this frog bump is but when he hops keep
the Frog bumps whatever the [ __ ] he
wants I guess but yes
[Music]
you have five candy bars in a bowl you
take out three how many candy bars do
you have I I still have five yeah you
can't trick me do what chuck chuck wood
I'm gonna guess yes oh why they were
getting beat up name a body part that is
spelled the same backwards and forwards
penis tack
i-i-i-i okay it's all the equation for X
okay and minus negative four so you you
subtract four some nine 18 divided by 3
6 4 letter word you can tune a guitar
but you can't tuna fish tuna fish tuna
fish which handy you stir soup with my
right my left or mine either you you
don't use your hand you use a spoon use
a spoon meet me in tic-tac-toe okay okay
how many sizes cube at six all right
there's a bear poo in the woods yes this
quiz is odd but I guess not too terribly
hard oh it's all by zero it's still zero
okay boink what are you putting a
toaster bread not toast you put bread in
you get weird swims is the same forwards
backwards and upside down forwards
backwards it slows ya backwards it's not
it's smooth so no no the word swims how
many two thousand two twenty twenty
dollars and 11 cents okay
twenty dollars in four cents what no am
I sure
no I'm not sure yes okay I like this
press the K button okay twelve seconds
and why this I don't like this at all I
like this game game doubt then no good
also how many [ __ ] questions are
there what would have enough pressing
enter oh [ __ ] you how about this haha my
president on the keyboard big the word
is name forward backwards and upside
down okay but by your logic of the last
one if it's upside down it's still it's
not gonna be because the why is not else
okay how many days in a normal calendar
year 365 escape the dungeon
okay colors balls green small plane
crash and every single person on board
died select who survived no one did you
just everyone died what colors a brown
rubber red balls
red what's your favorite color red how
many days are in July 31
how many days are in Sept that you ever
do the thing triple your favorite March
April May June July August October
Argus September October 30 30 30 how
many days are in January 31 okay how
many days are in May or April May 31 I
don't like where this is going May days
are in April 30 okay
my days are in August 31
October 31 is weird how many months have
31 days 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 7 ok how many
months have 28 days now you all the
months have 28 days to go to 12 you
think you're yeah I do yeah I do yeah I
do
oh no how many questions are in this
quiz a hundred hi hundred fifty lower
110 higher 120 115 lower one one one
okay I'm almost there
oh god another one of these okay I'm
looking at everything okay three
paintings of all pink bear blue bag red
shoes orange lamp blue bat blue blue bag
blue bag blue bag what is the 11-letter
word that even all Harvard graduates
spelt incorrectly is it the word
incorrectly one two three four five six
I made eleven incre incorrectly yeah hey
at some point between the years 1900 to
1999 there was a year that could be read
the same with a red right side up to
were upside down what year was it it's
not 1991 because upside-down that would
be 1661 not 1991 says read the same what
else would it be
it's not 1991 but that's the only thing
I can real thing god yeah it wasn't what
would it have been how many questions
are left okay if there's 111 questions
that means there's 535 okay aqua is
another word for water a chicken all
right
this is good stuff I only got four left
what is my name my name is mark hi nice
to be nice to be yeah which one is a
separate well not very drawn very well
but that one Alice's 14 on her birthday
she gets in the car and heads towards
our friend Samantha tossed it the same
type of friend Emily starts cycling at
the speed of 10 miles per hour short
Samba hauled was Alice she was Alice is
14 on her birthday
Alice is 14 how old was she she was 13
yeah okay yeah okay find that fill in
the missing letters in order to form
words in the horizontal and vertical
directions gel eye gel leg that makes
sense
done okay there are eight miles of woods
by your house how far can you walk into
the woods as far as you want far as you
want
goddammit [ __ ] a pyrotechnician should
know how fire works all right okay what
is more powerful than God the devil evil
itself or its people if you're having it
but poor people could be described as
having it is it nothing it's not
diseased all right okay I'm a SAP for
tree jokes I didn't know this was gonna
be the quiz of puns which shape is
around red rubber ball Spears not a
circle it's a sphere click the red
button is that the one with the word red
on it or the red button okay which one's
the elephant okay this is a square the
only shape with four sides know there's
rhombi and rectangles and diamonds right
a bit that's Texas was the first word in
the sentence what okay oh [ __ ] give me
the nuke ma'am oh [ __ ]
all right how many rabbits - six Oh God
13 oh my god what the [ __ ] [ __ ] you this
is the world's easiest game sure okay
ten seconds I got nothing I'm gonna do
nothing and I got nothing to do -
nothing - ciao all right I'm almost
there
that's try that that's a triangle it's
my dog blue there's my dog oh oh [ __ ]
you
oh [ __ ] you
what the [ __ ] don't there we go okay
[ __ ] [ __ ] eight I'd really don't
trust this game right now
Capote Catholic I don't trust you
centennial anniversary celebration how
many years it's a hundred that's Alaska
[Music]
I'm gonna guess 101 yay
what is a round red rubber ball made of
rubber unicorn horn of the Capitol in
New York Albany not New York City is a
moon made of cheese or the Sun in the
liverworts closin in the early morning
rose
not roof yay was doing to put together
for 22 ha
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you you piece of [ __ ] the
ball in the basket okay
don't trust you it's the first weight
Jupiter Mars Pluto over the moon it's
Pluto which country is bigger United
States all right tic-tac-toe rematch
well it all comes down to this huh all
right look you made it easy on me here's
another shot at the ones you missed
careful you only have two lives what do
you mean I got a redeem I don't know
what this is what is that was a year
that could be read the same with a read
write right side up or upside down what
year was it
wait 1960-1961
right that's it okay I don't know whose
house it was I don't know I don't know
was it Chris okay what are mm Oh what
are two thousand four pennies worth if I
had read that out rau LaHood I'll grout
I would have gotten that they're worth
0.01 dollars because they're the year
2004 is the moon made of cheese sure
okay let's go with that what a better
cats are dogs
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you how far can you walk
into the woods
halfway oh that's right if it's a if
it's an eight mile circle of woods you
can only walk into it halfway and then
you're in the center of it halfway and
then you're in the center of it that's
it the word swims is the same forward
Baxter's in the upside down okay
whatever let's just go with true cuz
they're wrong on that one but I'm not
gonna that's way too long that was not
the world's easiest game oh it's just a
bunch of puns and [ __ ] but either
way that is the world's easiest game if
you want try this for yourself go right
for and even though I answered all the
questions for you but maybe if you just
skip to the end of this video pause it
and then go play for yourself I'm sure
there's other easy games like this
quote-unquote easy games like this but
this is one so thank you everybody so
much for watching let me know what you
thought down the comments below let me
know how you did in the comments below
and as always I will see you
in the next video
[Music]